my quest off has been with us before and
very strong opinions on obviously
special teams st. special teams coach
who joins us now
coach walk us through this new proposed
kickoff rule who's it going to affect
the most that's a good question
Dan who's is going to affect the most I
think you're gonna see at the end of the
day I think I think you're gonna see
more returns than we have in the past I
think you're going to see more you'll
see we'll find out
the idea and we talked about this a
couple of weeks ago was to is to slow
down the collision the proximity so what
they're doing and they've done two
things one number one when they you're
gonna kick off from the 35 the same the
coverage team the coverage team has to
be evenly distributed spaced out you
can't overload things like that so there
are even stray stuff but they have to be
lined up a yard from the ball so they're
lined up at the 45
excuse me 34 yard line and they can't
move until the ball is kicked so they're
not gonna have a real whole head of
steam going down the field now the
return team then you have a 10 yard
restraining line the return team within
the next ten yards has to line up eight
players so the idea of it is is that
they would take their blocks on in a
closer proximity there is no more wedge
you cannot double-team with a front line
guy and a back guy like we used to do
you can't do that so they're going to
eliminate they're going to slow that
down some but the idea of the whole
thing is to make the play safer I think
I think it's got a little bit out of
whack yeah with this with the statistics
with injuries because last year there
were 18 concussions on kickoffs they
used the percentage only on the returns
oh there was a million balls that were
touched back so I want to see it used on
the whole play totally the play is not a
you know it's a violent play but it can
be made safer and we can use our heads
they're trying to do that this is a step
in the right direction I don't think
it's perfect but I do like it and I
think it's a step in the right direction
they're trying to do this but Mike is
there any downside to this yeah there's
some there is
downside there's some downside to the
fact of exactly house is all going to
take place you know who how exactly you
know to how it's going to be officiated
and to make sure that they've got this
perfect because you're not allowed as a
frontline guy to move forward when the
balls kicked in the air you can't go
forward and hit anyone so there's gonna
be a little bit of gray area there I
think it'll be worked out and I think
they'll they'll take places they'll have
that figured out see what I wanted to do
when I proposed it back in 2010 I took
this into the NFL office and drew this
up actually and we proposed it I wanted
to kick off from the 25-yard line but I
wanted the blocks to have to be taken on
before you got to the 50 so I definitely
wanted to make sure that the blocks were
taken on in a closer proximity more like
a punt return than a true kickoff return
where we had the big collisions and I'll
take a lot of that responsibility
because I think I had a lot to do with
that double-teaming and trapping and we
were pretty darn successful doing it but
that that's where that's where the
violence to the play came in so there's
some gray areas to be worked out and I
think I had a long talk with Troy
Vincent the other day but I do like the
fact that they're trying to keep a play
but yet make it safer they're really
trying but if I ask the players and just
let the players vote on this what are
the players voting on that's a good
question depends on who you ask all of
them that the whole league not just not
just special teamers but I if I did your
special teams guys both sides they're
gonna vote to keep the play they're
gonna keep it if you can make it a
little safer fine but I think most of
the guys like to play
I like the idea I like the idea of not
making the game singular I don't want
the game to all be about just a
quarterback I want the game to be about
a whole football team that has a chance
to help to win the football game they're
eliminating a lot of special teams plays
if this place eliminated you'll see a
reduction in roster within a couple
years I'm telling you right now I don't
care what anyone else says that's going
to happen I know that's why I don't want
it to happen but yet I don't think you
have to throw it out there's a lot of
people that would take it out they truly
don't understand it I only coached 31
years in the NFL and I
ever used the term wedge buster in my
life I never asked anyone to run down
and run into the front of a pickup truck
that's a stupidest thing I ever heard
those things get thrown out of whack
there's there is a violence to the play
but yet there's also a violence to the
quarterback throwing the ball across the
middle of the field is setting the wide
receiver up I mean come on we have to
all work together to help make this the
team sport that I think is so great and
there it's not the easiest now I'm not I
don't have I don't have a perfect answer
but we're headed I think it's they think
this is a step in the right direction
but coach what about the onside kick
there's no running start that really
takes away your advantage okay
only there's no running start in other
words you can't go up and block it if
the ball is kicked in the air which is
really interesting
don't don't think for a second that I as
a coach haven't been talking with the
guys because I'm still in I'm in Florida
I'm had to rehab for a surgery I had
before I go back I'm on the phone every
day we're practicing all this stuff I
put it all in already practicing
everything how to do these things
differently you're not going to see the
overloaded onside kick because the
coverage team has to remain a particular
spacing so it's going to change the
strategy and the methodology of onside
kicking it's going to be interesting to
see who comes up with the best plan and
how who figures it out that's a real
challenge for a coach trust me
I've already done a heck of a lot of
drawing trying to figure this one out of
trying to get ahead of this can that
this is all going to be part of it you
will not see it the same as it was but
also you won't see that you know that
kick right into the ground
the big highway up in the air and
everybody's you know jamming each other
into a pile you're not gonna see that
it'll be a little different it'll be
very interesting to see how it is you
want me to hit somebody right now like
no it's part of football but at the same
time you know you I always taught you
play you play below the shoulders and
above the knees and we're not interested
in some cheap shot I took great pride
and how physical the teams that I
coached are but yet I take no pride in a
cheap shot and knocking the heck out of
somebody I'm thinking that's the way the
game should be played you got to do this
right this is a tough sport it's not for
everybody but at the same time you know
we can make it a little bit safe and I
think this is
step to make it safer is it perfect I
don't know then I'm not sure that but I
know it's headed in the right direction
a lot better than then just put it out
and play flag football they're doing
that in the fifth grade coach thanks for
joining us we appreciate your time
thanks for asking me and I appreciate
your talking about it's an interesting
subject that's my quest off the Saints
special teams coach for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]